hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his explorations of the human emotion
of anger in the summative
Prima sakunde there are several places
where Thomas Aquinas is going to chart
out the relationship between the emotion
of anger and our human capacity actually
something essential to us
of rationality or Reason and there's
really two main places among others
where he does mention it one of them is
question 46 article four the other is
just a little bit later in the Soma
question 48 article 3. now in question
46 Article 4 the Black Friars has this
decent translation is angry rational act
but the word Act is not actually coming
up there the Latin simply reads
if we wanted a more literal translation
it's pretty simple is anger with reason
meaning does anger involve reason is it
compatible with reason or rationality
and as usual he begins with three you
know arguments three objections that can
be made to the view that anger actually
is with reason the first one is that it
seems that anger is not with reason as
an emotion anger is in the sense
appetite in apotitu sensitivo right
there's no discussion of imagination
there as there is in some other places
where it gets translated as sense
appetite and he says well the sense
appetite responds to things that it it
apprehends through the senses right
it reacts not uh following the
apprehension of reason but the
apprehension of the sensitive parts that
is our our sense organs right so he says
it's clear then it has to do with the
senses it's not a rational act so it's
not involving reason in any important
way
and um the second he says that
um
animals feel anger clearly the case
right unless we think that animals
displays of emotions are just mechanical
processes and don't have anything to do
with that which Thomas doesn't think so
he says listen animals other than us
lack reason but they get angry so
there's no intrinsic connection between
anger and reason and then finally the
third one that he brings up is kind of
interesting he says that listen people
get drunk all the time and when they get
drunk uh that hampers the use of reason
right this is sort of a commonplace but
drunk people also get angry easier or
more intensely again something we could
kind of verify with our own experience
so drinking on the one hand represses
reason but also increases anger clearly
that means there's no real connection
between the two and then Tom says yeah
but Aristotle says anger is with reason
and so we've got to see whether this
actually does make sense and so he says
how can we understand this well
anger is a desire for Revenge he tells
us and what is Revenge involve uh
inflicting punishment for the injury
that has been suffered right we want to
whether we're right or not we want to
inflict uh retribution or Vindication by
doing something to the person that we
think has harmed or injured or insulted
us or those we care about and this as he
says is going to involve
reason to some degree Aristotle says
anger
reasoning actually the word there is
silo gone siligizing as it were that
anything like this must be fought
against boils up straight away so
clearly for Aristotle and for Thomas
anger does involve reason in some
respect and so there's two functions
that he brings up here inference uh
confere you know literally bearing
things together and then uh what gets
translated as deduction
it could be deduction in a strict sense
it could be in a loosey-goosey sense but
anger does draw inferences it is a
semi-rational process it uses
rationality so Thomas says that there is
a connection between the two and then
when he's addressing these he says an
appetite of reaction can involve reason
or include reason in two ways so one way
would be the ACT is actually commanded
by reason and he says that's not the
case with anger but it is the case with
the will right the voluntas which is
with reason in this respect and that's
why it's called the rational appetite
then he says second the ACT may be
motivated by reason and this is the way
in which anger involves reason how so
well something happens we we notice it
with our senses but we reason about it
and the reasoning tells us go take you
know revenge on this person Aristotle
says anger involves reason not as
commanding but as revealing an injury
and so then he says something else that
I think is really quite interesting here
that is would be worth following up the
Sensei appetite is responsive to reason
not immediately but through the
intervention said mediante of the will
the voluntas so the will is in some
respect involved in this uh inferential
process in a way that hasn't been quite
clarified at this point what about the
um
the other uh objections that we could
make well
um animals as Thomas is going to say at
a number of points animals have Instinct
they also have imagination right uh
imaginatio which we share with them and
that allows them to draw inferences that
are kind of like reasons so that they
can engage in Practical action including
feeling emotions like anger so you know
yes animals strictly speaking don't have
reason but they have something analogous
to it so this this idea then means that
anger in us really could be connected
together with rationality which we rely
upon rather than the animal instincts
um the third one he says we read in the
ethics anger listens to reason to some
extent in that reason discovers an
injury but it is not perfectly attentive
because in exacting Revenge
it is not regulated by reason now
we should think about that sometimes it
can be like you know when anger is
virtuous but Thomas isn't concerned with
that here he says their anger therefore
this is very interesting both requires
and impedes rational
activity right
some sort of Act of reason is needed at
aditour impedimentum rationes and it
also brings or contributes some
impediment to reason so those who are
drunk uh when they have lost all
rational capacity Aristotle says they
don't get angry they can't infer
anything right they're so drunk that
they can't reason at all but when
they're slightly drunk he says they're
angered because they're capable of
reasoning even if it's in perfectly now
this impeding is going to be an
important idea which is now going to
come up in question 48 right in article
3.
which again does anger notably interfere
with the ability to reason utram Ira
Maxime and pediat raziones usom and
pediat interfere with impede same thing
right so it's the same matter the same
function that's being referenced here
and the ability to reason is uses
so the literally the use the putting
into effect of of Reason does anger
interfere with this
and he begins with again three arguments
saying nah it doesn't interfere with
reason the first one is that what is
done reasonably clearly not a hindrance
to reason but anger is responsive to
reason or is with reason again
so therefore anger doesn't hinder the
use of reason it actually involves the
use of Reason how could it possibly
interfere with it uh the second one is
very interesting the angry person is
open and straightforward they're not
hiding anything from you and so in a
certain way that that seems more like
the use of Reason doesn't it he says
um an angry man is not devious but quite
open so anger does not interfere with
the operation of reason as does sense
desire concupiscence right
which is insidious insidiosa is is the
Latin and then the third one this is
really quite uh an interesting argument
because rational judgment stands out
more sharply by contrast to its contrary
what does he mean there so rational
judgment judgment that is being
exercised by reason when you look at
non-rational judgments judgments made on
other bases there's a stark contrast
between them and so this helps you see
what the rational is better and he says
anger is heightened or grown literally
in the same way right you put things
side by side you draw a stark contrast
he's got an example here men are more
angered by treatment which clashes with
their present condition as Honorable Men
when they are they are insulted so
they're feeling you know their honor and
then it's insulted now there's a big
contrast or a contradiction action they
become more angry when that happens and
he's taking this from Aristotle so he
says the same sort of thing
x-aodem you know from the same sort of
thing
anger is intensified or grown and the uh
rational judgment
is also
um aided you could say
so clearly again anger is not a
impediment it's not interfering with
rational judgment now
the I respond that the responsio Thomas
is giving his own position here he
actually talks about the mind-body
connection or at least touches upon it
and he tells us that
um
mind or Reason Manziel ratio does not
use a physical organ in its own proper
operation but
that doesn't mean that it's not affected
by the body right it does require
certain sense Powers whose functioning
as interfered with by a physical
disturbance what would the physical
disturbance in the case of anger be well
Aristotle had called anger a boiling of
blood around the heart Thomas you know
is willing to say it's not just the
heart it's the other organs as well
anger produces physiological
reactions which then do interfere with
our reasoning processes even though
reason is not just reducible say to
what's going on in our brain so if
that's the case then he says it clearly
manifests to you or
impedes impedance rational judgment
so is this the same thing as the use of
Reason rational judgment is a particular
or you could say a very common use of
our rational faculties and so anger
would because of how it works
screw with it a bit and then you know
the responses to his uh the initial
arguments are actually quite lengthy
here he says reason is operative in the
origin of anger right the arising of
anger
um with respect to its formal element uh
a appetite of reaction right a
modem opative so reason is involved in
the cause of how anger works and then he
says anger itself interferes with
perfect reasoning by not completely
obeying reasons
demands reasons injunctions it's it's
judgments right so this is perfectly
along the lines of what we're talking
before anger you know Aristotle says is
like a hasty servant it listens to a
part of what's being said then Russia's
off it sees that there's injury or
insult and it immediately infers to uh I
should do something about this and that
is impeding rational judgment uh so he
says this is due to the agitation of
body heat once again we go to this
physical uh discussion this physical
interpretation the material element in
Anger which impels one to react swiftly
I mean could we reconstruct this along
lines that don't involve boiling of
blood around the heart probably so we
could talk about what goes on in the
brain and what else is happening in the
body right and we can talk about like
you know hormones adrenaline you know
cortisol things like that
uh the second one is responding to this
issue that the angry person is open
straightforward above the board they're
not hiding anything and so the idea is
this wouldn't interfere with reasoning
because reason is also you know
something that's we're conscious of and
he says an angry person is said to
betray their intentions because they
behave in a straightforward Manner and
they do not try to conceal them not in
the sense that they understand clearly
what they ought to be doing right uh
sibi quidfakare Deborah debiat right so
the Deborah is what they what they
should do and then the sibi you know
they're lacking a kind of sense about
what they ought to do and oftentimes
they think they should do other things
like yell at people break things attack
you know and this is not what they
actually should be doing so
it is interfering with reason to some
extent and then he's got this
interesting discussion uh or analogy to
magnanimy right being open being uh sort
of above things literally having a great
soul
and he says that
um
you know this is also an example of the
expansion of the heart so again a
physical explanation and he says that
um
you know this doesn't prevent Anger from
interfering with with rationality the
fact that it's open you're just clear
about how your reasoning process is
screwed up
um what about the the third one this
this idea of like
making things
clearer by by using contrasts so here
Thomas is going to point some stuff out
and he really seems to be more or less
conceding the argument that's being made
he says an angry reaction is set off by
reason so reasoning is part of the
reaction and in this respect the
comparison of contrary is both AIDS
rational judgment and increases anger so
so far so good right so when uh here's
the example he uses when a person enjoys
wealth and the respect of others and
then suffers the loss of some sort the
law seems to be greater
both because of the contrast and because
it had not been anticipated greater
sadness or disturbance or pain trastitia
results which then leads to Greater
anger
here he doesn't seem to be saying that
anger is interfering with the reasoning
process so this response isn't really
going against the argument that was
originally made but Thomas has plenty of
ways already in which anger is clearly
interfering with our reasoning
capacities our use of reason our
judgments notice that for Thomas a lot
of this does depend on the physical
causality we might say the Mind Body
interaction which he mentions at several
points so these are two important
articles in which Thomas is showing to
us how anger and rationality something
that is essential to us as human beings
how these actually come together but
also how anger can interfere with the
full use of that very rationality